presidential election in fold again how
the right stole the 2004 election and
why they'll steal the next 12 unless we
stop them he spoke for about 90 minutes
to an audience at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst it's my great
pleasure to introduce mark millar who
teaches in the culture and communication
program at NYU and is one of the world's
leading scholars in the area of the mass
media and politics I first got to know
mark through his book in the early 90s
boxed in the culture of television which
featured essays on a number of important
topics including race and The Cosby Show
something that I was working on at the
same time mark also wrote a pioneering
early essay on product placement in
Hollywood movies pointing to the dangers
of corporate colonization at NYU he was
director of a group called promo the
project on media ownership which did
outstanding work in tracking patterns of
media ownership and in fact the Nation
magazine ran a number of special issues
based on that work more recently he's
the author of three books dealing with
the bush-cheney administration and the
dangerous conservative movement that is
driving it in fact he's one of the few
commentators honest enough and bold
enough to use the f-word fascism they
describe the political project that we
are slouching toward at present these
three books the bush dyslexic on cruel
and unusual and the latest one fooled
again how the right stole the 2004
election and why they'll steal the next
one unless we stop them are I think a
remarkable attempt to intervene in this
evolving profoundly unamerican project
of what he terms in even more kind of
accurate terms as Christo fascism that
is a lethal mixture of evangelical
fervour and ruthless state power at this
moment of crisis the conference is
called crisis in communication that this
moment of crisis what is most needed
from intellectuals is clear thinking and
analysis so we can properly understand
that
the faces further that knowledge needs
to become active not just in academia
not just in horse like this but in the
world and in fact it's notable that
during the last election mark released a
DVD of his one-man State show entitled
Patriot Act which featured him
performing on stage the very things he
was writing about in his books in that
sense Mark Miller I think is one of our
most important and fearless public
intellectuals bold and incisive he
demonstrates the moral necessity of
academics breaking out of the ivory
tower if our democracy is to survive the
current assaults will be bound to
scholar activist like him please welcome
what can I possibly say now what can I
say okay its homeland security I cast an
eye at the program for this conference
and I was surprised to see how many
things are in crisis you get the
impression that many different
disciplines are in crisis many subfields
are in crisis you haven't seen anything
yet we're in a worst crisis than I ever
would have thought possible when I first
started doing this kind of work so I'm
here to give you some harrowing news but
I'm also here to give you some very
encouraging news which shouldn't be news
it should be stuff we know already but
because it's never been reported and the
general consensus is against it it will
come as news I'm going to talk about my
new book which i happen to have here for
the camera fooled again I can't think of
a more appropriate place to talk about
this than hear that because the book is
a tremendous interest to anyone
interested in media study and so on but
so is the experience I have had trying
to make the book known it's been the
object of a national press blackout
since it came out in november and i will
talk about that and try to hit all the
bases let me begin by telling a story
about a meeting I had with John Kerry in
late two thousand and three now at this
time I was part of a network of people
who were deeply concerned about the
insidious spread of electronic
touchscreen voting machines all over the
country it's a serious problem first of
all those machines are eminently
hackable secondly they leave no paper
trail
third their programming codes are
proprietary information and forth there
are all manufactured by private vendors
that have long close relations with the
Republican Party that seems to me to be
a bit problematic and yet no one was
talking about it it was as if it wasn't
happening well we you know had every
reason to believe that the bush-cheney
campaign might not handle things in the
most upright and right irony heavy irony
anyway I made it my mission to try to
talk to as many of the contenders for
the Democratic nomination as I could to
see if I could get them to discuss the
issue so as I say I got invited to a
fundraiser for Kerry this is late two
thousand three was in Manhattan and I
had to tell him all the things I just
said to you all the things about
touchscreen voting machines that I
thought he should know and talk about in
a very short space of time so I I didn't
know the guy and I was ushered into his
presence I stood there looking up at him
it was a huge huge enormously tall
looking down at me and I ran through
this this recitation and he was wearing
a look of grave concern though is I
think he did this a week and then I
finished and I i could tell that i
hadn't made an impression on him that
what I said went in one ear and out the
other and in a way I can't blame him
because this was all news to him and
that was that he was the last of the
Democratic contenders to mention the
problem of electronic touchscreen
machines Howard Dean was first and then
Kucinich brought it up and carry
eventually said something about it at
any rate we all know what happened then
or I should say we all think we know
what happened then that is Carrie ran
and lost handily to george w bush who
made a miraculous showing in the 2004
election well it was so miraculous that
i couldn't i really couldn't get past
the anomalous pneus of this win because
here was a here was a guy who had
disapproval ratings in the high 40's a
guy facing a party that for a change the
Democratic Party was for a change
fiercely United they had outdone the
Republicans at registering new voters in
the swing states by as much as five to
one the turnout was extraordinarily high
by American standards it was over sixty
percent and the Republican Party was
divided before Election Day a lot a very
prominent Republican some of them quite
conservative had come out publicly
urging people not to vote for Bush for
reelection bob bar of georgia you know
it was now a consultant to the aclu came
out with a very strong op-ed not
endorsing carry but saying that george w
bush is not a conservative so you know
it would be dangerous to vote for him
and he made this argument of three
grounds foreign policy economic policy
and above all the threat to civil
liberties well Bob Barr was by no means
alone John Eisenhower Dwight Sun came
out with an effete endorsing Kari
Francis Fukuyama the neoconservative
guru was he recently made a statement
against the administration but before
the election he also said he did not
think Bush should be reelected Doug band
out the Cato Institute general Tony
mcpeek of the Air Force who had been a
veteran for Bush in two thousand this is
a lot of people and some sixty
newspapers that had backed bush in two
thousand now refused to back them in
2004 newspapers in the so-called red
states two-thirds of them endorsed carry
but all of them refused to endorse bush
Financial Times endorsed carry the
Economist endorsed Kerry so if the
Republican Party was the party of big
capital they had kind of funny way of
showing their allegiance to Bush and yet
he won we're told with 11 and a half
million more votes than he got in two
thousand eleven and a half million more
votes now this struck me as
statistically and demographically
impossible eleven and a half million
votes what was the reason for this
victory well we are told by the press
which got this point from the religious
right that it was an enormous outpouring
of pious partisanship that lofted Bush
back into the Oval Office that millions
and millions multitudes of evangelic
ELLs multiplying like Jesus loaves and
fishes just kind of appear they
materialize or they came down from on
high and they voted they swept many a
pious Catholic and you with them and low
the president was reelected by eleven
and a half million more votes than he
got in two thousand there's a big
problem with this claim that is that
there are not enough evangelicals to
account for that margin throughout the
campaign Karl Rove kept telling us that
there were four million evangelical four
million who had not voted for Bush in
two thousand and the party's aim here
was to get those four million to come
out and vote for Bush well let's be
generous and pretend that they succeeded
in getting all four million of those at
angelicas to vote for Bush let's even be
more generous and say that they let
those four million voters each vote for
Bush twice
still doesn't explain the 11 and a half
million I mean something is patently
fishy here and there were exit polls in
five states that foretold a Kerry
victory and then Bush won in those
states by that margin of victory now
whereas in Ukraine we used the exit
polls as the basis for supporting the
dissident movement the challenge to the
incumbent here our official response was
to say oh oh the exit polls diverge from
the boat cali i guess we have to throw
out the exit polls or just them they
adjusted them well I felt compelled
having written two books about bush
cheney as posing a dire and I think
unprecedented threat to American
democracy I felt I got to write a book
about this too so I started to look into
it and the evidence is copious the
evidence is overwhelming it's not
supposition it's not conspiracy theory
all across the country not just in Ohio
all across the country the bush machine
did whatever it might take they used a
broad variety of tricks and tactics in
order to do everything possible to cut
the Kerry vote and pad the bush vote now
this varied from state to state but not
all that much in state after state we
know of 21 states where there were many
many complaints of the electronic touch
screen machine systematically flipping
carry votes into Bush votes it happened
in Ohio but happened in Tennessee it
happened in Kentucky it happened in
Wisconsin happened in Pennsylvania
haven't all over the place now I've
looked long and hard and I've managed to
find four claims that the touch screen
machines flipped bush votes in to carry
boats they're all in Texas you know I
don't know if they're if they're
accurate or not the machines are quite
easy to you know mess with so maybe it
happened
but there's no statistical possibility
that could have happened so many cases
benefiting one party without there being
some some guidance from above in state
after state after state not just Ohio
there was a systematic undersupply of
voting machines to Democratic precincts
but there were long long lines all over
the country only in democratic areas now
these are just a couple of examples of
the kinds of things that went on and in
state after state after state the
results were anomalous they were
surprising in red states as well as blue
for example in North Carolina Bush was
supposed to win by six points he won by
15 now a number of people have examined
the absentee ballots and the early
valladine and found that the absentee
ballots in the early balloting actually
gave force six percent advantage only
the Machine count on Election Day gave
him a 15-point advantage so it happened
in red states and it happened in blue
states happening was we're in 2000 Bush
lost by 100,000 votes 94,000 went to
nader the others went to Gore this time
Bush lost by only 12,000 votes in a blue
state you start to look into the things
that went on in Milwaukee in madison and
Kenosha and Racine it was a veritable
crusade the disenfranchised Bush's
political opposition so there is as I
say copious evidence now wrote the book
and it was my naive belief that having
laid out this case with great care it
would be possible now to talk about the
likelihood that the election was stolen
in 2004 not with an eye toward removing
Bush from office because there's no
constitutional way to do that my primary
purpose
writing the book was to jumpstart a
national movement for election reform
because if we don't deal with this
problem if we don't fix the election
system so that it's trustworthy
trustworthy by all if we cannot vote our
representatives and our president in and
out of office we can make progress on no
other front this experiment is finished
this is the crucial issue there is no
other issue is important in fact it's
not just an issue it's the whole ball
game this Tom Paine said the freedom to
vote is is the very you know fulcrum on
which all other freedoms the basis in
which all our other freedoms stand so by
coincidence I got myself invited to
another fundraiser for John Kerry in
late October of 2005 the book came out a
week later somebody very close to carry
shares my concern about the integrity of
the election system and got me invited
to a fundraiser to give him the book a
little face time with them and see if I
could get him to focus on it and so on
because you know his concession I
believe was a disaster demoralized
everybody was premature to say the least
and anyway it's not about him it's about
the voters okay there he was again I had
the book I held it aloft let's get that
shot I said you were robbed senator he
said I know just like that I know and
they started a complaint about the fact
that his fellow Democrats on the hill
won't discuss it with him couldn't
believe it they don't want to talk about
it he told me the week before he had had
a big argument with chris dodd of
connecticut telling dodd look these
machines there's all kinds of reasons
why they're unreliable he said da just
got mad so we looked into this there's
no story there I Carrie was staggered by
this
so they're in denial I need evidence to
persuade these people you have evidence
in your book I said yeah yeah there's as
I said to him and as I've said elsewhere
there is copious evidence that they
stole the election there's actually no
evidence that they want it I mean the
official numbers that's evidence that
they want but I you know I challenge
anyone to come up with any other
evidence that they won there's a lot of
evidence to the contrary and I pointed
out to him the GAO report how many of
you have heard of the GAO report suree
that don't feel bad because the press
never reported this the GAO at the
Government Accountability Office is the
research arm of Congress bipartisan I
mean it's not we're not talking about
the Komen turn here okay I guess that's
a rather dated joke we're not talking
about Pyongyang here no never mind we're
talking about a very establishment
entity came out with a report in
mid-october of 2005 giving detailed
reasons why the voting machines aren't
trustworthy and these are machines that
were then being an hour still being
shoehorned into state after state after
state for us to conduct our elections I
said to carry there's the GAO report he
said oh the GAO came out with a report
which he gave me pause and I you know I
didn't say what I wanted to say which
was what is your staff in a coma for I
wanted to say but I didn't say that it
would have been in politic I said yes
and he was suitably impressed so I said
look in the spirit of your
investigations of BCCI and Iran Contra
in the Senate which I consider the high
points of the Senate serves there were
great investigations I think that you
should take this issue on it's not just
about your political career although you
know it will benefit you enormously
because the grassroots level Democrats
are really upset about this and angry
about
but it's also you know American
democracy can't survive unless there is
an investigation of this he was
sympathetic he was receptive he said I
that does have to be done someone has to
do it I don't know if I'm the one to do
it because of the sour grapes factor I
said that's a problem but I promise you
if you look at the evidence you can say
you know with perfect confidence that
you were skeptical but having studied
the situation you've come reluctantly to
the conclusion that there was something
very wrong with that election for the
good of the country etc is writing a
speech broom so instead this is great
I'll read it will talk he socked me on
the arm he did and he gave me a thumbs
up I felt special I went out for a pass
you know he didn't go that far so I was
he went off to you know glad hand and
raise money and so on and I was just I
was exhilarated because here the party
had been completely mum on this issue
and the man who had conceded hastily
conceded prematurely the nominal head of
the Democratic Party was saying to me
and this was not off the record this was
he didn't say just between us or
anything like that he was telling me yet
I think they stole her and I think that
my colleagues on the hill or in denial
so that was a Friday Friday October 28th
following tuesday i started to promote
the book and i took to telling this
story at the events where I talked about
the book because it had a galvanizing
effect on people I me sometimes the
galvanized feeling was strongly tinged
with anger you know why don't he say
this before still it was you know far
better whether it was angry or not it
was infinitely preferable to the sort of
funk that everybody was in and many
people are still in the sense there are
more of them than us they have
outnumbered us we're hopeless we're
helpless we're Munich's we can't do
anything what can we
but to hear that Carey basically
acknowledged the extreme likelihood of
theft was was [ __ ] people up so then I
was on a week later on the next friday i
was on Amy Goodman's Democracy Now told
the story again the producers got very
excited they sent out a press release
saying Kerry believes the race was
stolen and within hours his office
released a statement categorically
denying he had the conversation with me
granting that I did give him the book
but denying that we'd had the
conversation now this this I was
flabbergasted and I was flowery asked it
for this reason there was a guy who told
me that he thinks the race was stolen
and he deplored the fact that his fellow
Democrats in Washington are in denial on
the subject as soon as I told the story
publicly he immediately snapped into
that same posture of denial and I tell
this story because I think it will help
us to understand why the Democrats and
to some extent the press have been
almost completely silent on this issue
Democrats will not talk about this some
of them actually give reasons why they
will not talk about this and the reasons
are always patently absurd for example
Bernie Sanders of Vermont running for
the Senate completely progressive guy
highly intelligent he says we really
shouldn't talk about this issue because
if we do people might not come out to
vote how do you like that logic
don't say anything let them come out to
vote okay then the Republicans can throw
those votes away and then people will be
even more depressed than they were in
the first place I ran into Jerry Nadler
on the train coming back from one of the
events on Mike Tori's my congressman
great guy progressive is on the House
Judiciary Committee the Conyers
committee he helped work on the Conyers
report studying what happened in Ohio so
he knows what's going on I said to him
on the train what's going on this is
November now what's going on in
Washington what are you guys doing to
try and fix the election system he said
well you know look Bush won Ohio by what
four hundred thousand votes I mean that
means he would have won anyway despite
the cheating now Bush won Ohio by a
hundred and eighteen thousand votes
that's considerably less than 400,000 I
believe that Jerry Nadler came up with
that inflated number out of a need for a
kind of rationale not to do anything
because i think that the democrats by
and large are so frightened of the
implications of what went down in 2004
it is so radically shattering that they
just come up with a lot of reasons not
not really to admit that it happen they
are fundamentally in denial even Carrie
I mean Carrie could say to me yeah
they're in denial those guys but deep in
his heart of hearts he's in denial too
because it's very hard I think for a
lifelong Democrat a professional
politician a Washington insider to take
to heart the fact that the whole game
they're playing with the strategy and
you know the fundraising and all this
stuff is a complete waste of time they
could run the most brilliant campaign
ever conceived by man they could run
Jesus Christ himself as their candidate
and they would still lose
now what this means is that business as
usual can't go on what this means is we
don't live in a democracy we live in
something else what this means is that
the nation that is now oversees trying
to impose democracy at gunpoint and
another people doesn't have a democracy
itself and yet here in this country
there is not a peep about it in the
press in fact the New York Times just
last week when a couple of front page
stories about those plucky election
reform activists in Belarus is yet
belarus i mean god bless them in belarus
I'm not trying to take anything away
from them but it's it's very interesting
to me that it's always a very important
matter you know election reform is an
important matter as long as it's in
Ukraine in Iraq and Belarus because we
can point those closed societies and say
not not like here well see this is a
direct challenge to many many people's
dearest notions about this country and
therefore extremely difficult for them
to face especially people in the
political establishment I have found in
my travels with this book that the
grassroots gets it and that it's not
really a partisan issue it is a civic
issue a civic issue of profound
importance and people get it people
aren't dumb that's that's in essence the
good news that I have to report today is
that we didn't vote to reelect this guy
and we never would I don't believe the
election was even close I mean read the
book take it out of the library I don't
care where you buy it or not there are
other books too Steve framing of the
University of Pennsylvania has a great
book coming out in a few months is the
Conyers report this terrific work by Bob
Petraeus and harvey wasserman in ohio
they published several books they have a
website called free press the evidence
is actually building week by week of
evidence of vast republican malfeasance
all over the country
the press won't report it now why is
this what is it about this that's so
frightening I mean I've already argued
that it poses a very strong challenge to
our dearest notions of what this country
is there's another factor involved here
fooled again is not only a catalog of
all the tricks and tactics used to
disenfranchise the American majority it
is also an analysis of the mentality
that I believe largely drove that
disenfranchisement what we're talking
about here is not just a policy issue
we're not just talking about the need
for paper ballots the need to hand count
those paper ballots the need to have a
uniform system of voting nationwide so
that every state has the same methods
and rules we need all that we need it
desperately but that's not what this is
about this is about something else this
is about the fact that the the theft of
this election was driven by something I
believe that's unprecedented and
presidential campaigning in our country
because let's face it election fraud is
not a new thing we've had election fraud
forever and both parties have committed
it I'm from Chicago okay nobody needs to
tell me the Democrats steal elections
I've watched Mayor Daley doing it
throughout my childhood and adolescence
and it was even struck this last time to
see the Christian Right playing some of
the tricks daily used to play so it's
not new it's not unprecedented but the
theft of the election in 2004 was
unprecedented in three ways first of all
in its scale because we're talking about
you know huge sectors of the population
were disenfranchised it was
unprecedented in its technical
sophistication is the use of these
electronic touchscreen machines to erase
votes
is especially insidious because it's
completely undetectable they can just
the press of a button you can alter a
vote count leaves no trace there's no
paper involved it's just lights in a box
it's just basically the word of the
company that makes the machines that's
all you have to go on but most
significant of all the theft of the
election in 2004 was unprecedented in
its motivation because this was not just
a matter of a political party breaking
the rules to hang on the power or a
political party breaking the rules to
seize power not just a matter of
political parties breaking the rules in
order to get more of the spoils those
are rational motivations and I think we
can all understand them they're not
admirable but they're rational to a
great extent the theft of the election
in 2004 was driven by a fierce hatred of
American democracy itself in order to
understand the mentality behind the
theft you have to understand that these
many of these people at the grassroots
level and elsewhere sincerely believe
that their political adversaries are
demonic evil you all evil agents of hell
you read their websites to read their
publications this is not a secret this
is how they see the other side as evil
and because the other side is so
completely evil the other side of course
eminently capable of doing anything to
win therefore we must use their methods
to prevent them from doing this to us
now this is the kind of paranoid
mentality that underlay the savage wars
on our frontiers throughout our history
the kind of mentality that drove the
great Crusades this mentality was at
work behind the Cold War you must use
methods every bit as insidious and sly
and ruthless as theirs to fight so great
a foe
and this is the way I believe bushes
base actually perceived the election not
as a contest between different ways of
looking at government you know not as a
struggle for people's votes but no this
is this is crucially important that we
do whatever needs to be done the ends
justify the means because what this
movement is after is not just corporate
profits it's not just oil if we continue
to think that then we're in denial
ourselves we're missing the significance
of a movement that has a strong
apocalyptic streak now you can say a lot
of things against corporate capitalism
not that anyone in here ever has but it
is it is a rational it has irrational
manifestations and irrational
consequences but it is a rational system
capitalism does not want to go up in
flames the fact is that the world's
financial elites are not happy about
Bush Chinese economic policies which are
suicidal their military policy is
suicidal they are destroying the
American military and rational off
military officers know this their
approach to the environment is not
dictated solely by big lumber and coal
and oil in the automobile industries
it's not it has theological roots it is
an apocalyptic movement that thinks of
the end of history not as a bad thing
but as the only good thing they want to
bring it on because when they bring it
on when they are in power and they bring
the world to an end he will return these
are post pawlenty lists now i'm not
talking about all evangelic all's far
from it i'm not talking about all
believers this is not a critique of
religion at all we're talking about an
extremist movement that is hijacked the
Republican Party and hijacked religious
conservatism it stands in roughly this
same relationship to the religious right
overall as the Communist Party did in
relation to the left and liberals in the
30s in other words this is the hardcore
this is for the real serious committed
CAD ray this stuff this is christian
reconstruction ism also known as
Dominion theology it is based on fervent
belief that it did the obligation of
every real Christian to work now for the
creation of what they call a Christian
Republic and you're the press will not
talk about this a few good books out
about it Esther Kaplan's book with God
on their side excellent book Stephanie
Hendricks has a short book called divine
destruction which is about the
theological roots of this
administration's anti environmentalism
michelle goldberg of salon has a book
coming out in a couple of months called
kingdom coming from norton which is also
about the religious right the books were
out there they don't get reviewed
there's a great book by christina page
of how the pro-choice movement saved
America just came out a month ago and it
makes an absolutely unassailable case
that the pro-life movement is not about
lessening the number of abortions the
pro-life movement is in fact opposed to
contraceptive measures that would do
just that the pro-life movement wants to
ban contraception that's what they want
this is a religious agenda this is a
direct systematic challenge to the
ideals of the Enlightenment so it's not
just a power grab by one party this is
the resurgence of a kind of animus that
the framers deliberately built this
country to frustrate this kind of we
might call it an evil this this
Manichean sensibility that sees the
world is divided into the forces of
light and the forces of darkness that
wants to bring on the last clash you
know this is the kind of fanatical
worldview that the guys who
the Constitution really wanted
consciously trying to thwart they did
not want that ever to happen here
consequently they separated church and
state formally in the First Amendment
this is nothing to apologize for this
was not a plot by you know Thomas
Jefferson and his snooty French friends
against the multitudes of pious
Americans because you know for most of
our history many many believing
Americans were deeply grateful for the
separation of church and state you know
the Baptist's used to be ardent
Jeffersonians on this matter why because
they understood that if there were a
state church they would end up being
persecuted by it I mean this was their
own historical experience so the
separation of church and state was fine
by them and one of the most articulate
defenders of the idea that there
shouldn't be theocracy the church and
state should be separated was Roger
Williams founder over Thailand who was
for all intents and purposes a Christian
fundamentalist and his arguments are
unassailable so you know the separation
of church and state is nothing to
apologize for it's something to boast of
and for that matter all the principles
of the Enlightenment you know
notwithstanding the enormous fact the
framers themselves betrayed those
principles in practice with slavery this
is all true but this does not cast any
kind of a shadow on those ideals it
simply represents the difficulty of
trying to realize them which you could
say is what defines the history of
America is a slow painful haphazard
effort to realize the ideals in the Bill
of Rights and in the Constitution and
this administration is intent on
preventing that from happening and there
is an enormously important theological
component to this effort now it's hard
for people to accept this because I'd
say generally speaking rational people
tend to project their own rationality on
to everybody else
so often when people warned of Hitler's
rise in the 30s you hear people saying
no no yeah very clever politician he
only says this kind of thing to appeal
to his base but he's really very clever
or he's just doing this to try to
intimidate Stalin but he's really quite
a talked to him and he is sure you know
this kind of thing it's very hard for us
to grasp that those at the top can be
irrational and I believe that this is in
fact a pathological movement it is not
conservative all those Republicans who
spoke out against the bush regime who
advised Republicans and conservatives
not to vote to reelect bush we're
absolutely right this is not a
conservative movement it's not about
limiting the size of federal government
our rights have been taken away they're
gone it doesn't matter whether we have
Arabic surnames or whether we live
somewhere else and have a passport in
effect we have no rights now habeas
corpus has been nullified this is this
is a very very serious situation
unprecedented now let me let me say
something about this occasion what we do
I've come to believe that it makes no
sense whatsoever to study media to do
media studies without constant reference
to what's happening in the world that's
my belief now I know that our profession
has been written in Twain for a long
time between the quantitative types and
the critical theory types and this goes
all the way back to the beginning the
quantitative approach is very much an
American thing has to do with the
national security state and the ryzza
the networks and so on and then there
were folks like adorno came over from
Germany with a different perspective and
we're more interested in a more
theoretical philosophically based
approach and so on I'm not going to take
sides in that battle because that battle
is at this point as irrelevant as the
Cold War it is
because the fact of the matter is that
much of the work that we do in this
field is not contending with the threat
that's facing this democracy has nothing
to do with it whether it's highly
quantitative analysis or something
written in a kind of theory speak that
no one outside of the profession can
understand you know crisis is not just a
theme for a conference okay crisis is
not just something for us to write
papers about before our peers I mean
understand the professional imperatives
that are driving us all I've tenure I
don't mean to be smug about it and in
fact I'm highly critical of all those
journalists many of them even on the
Left who refuse to deal with this issue
but I don't pretend that I wouldn't be
just like them if I didn't have tenure
it's true got to make a living we're all
skating on very thin ice now
economically it's very very easy to sort
of slip out of the middle class and into
something else and that's scary and a
lot of the journalists on the left or
freelancers you know these are material
considerations that I think drive them
whether they know it or not so when you
want to say something about the theft of
the election they'd much rather
advertise their moderate chops off
you're becoming let's let's be
reasonable here I mean obviously you're
a paranoid conspiracy theorist if we
take a sober look at the evidence and
talk to people in the know will discover
that it's a much more complicated
picture than you're saying now I've
heard this from many statisticians and
universities it's not based on science I
mean it it performs as if it is
scientific it has a white coat on it
acts very sage and very let's take a
look at all the evidence carefully shall
we instead of screaming and yelling like
you do but it's not scientific at all
it's based on voodoo it's based on say
so it's myth people of this country were
disenfranchised American democracy is
under serious attack and the confusing
part of it is or one of the confusing
aspects of it is that this just
to have anything to do with the
ideological clashes that we all grow up
with because we're all children of the
Cold War and we all thought all this
time that the long Twilight Struggle is
going to be capitalism versus socialism
and the left by and large taken the site
of socialism and the left is by and
large depended on a revolutionary
tradition from Europe right we talked
about Graham sheep we talked about marks
we talked about the French and so on now
with all due respect to them we have an
excellent revolutionary heritage of our
own and it is under attack yes I know
that the Christian Right doesn't like
post-modernism whatever they think that
is now they take potshots at i know
david horowitz complains about it they
should actually encourage the rise of
post-modernism they should keep
encouraging discussions of post-colonial
tea because it poses no threat
whatsoever to their power but they're so
filled with bile you see they're so
angry david horowitz it's just got such
problems you know like Rush and sean
hannity and all the rest of them this
movement is essentially one vast angry
projection by people who hate things
inside themselves this is why there's so
much homophobia in that movement it's a
movement of closet cases I really do
believe we're not dealing with
conservatives and we're not dealing even
with economic or economist ichthyology
it is the pathology of paranoia it is
the same animus that drove the Crusades
it is the same animus that drove the
savage wars on our frontiers it is the
same animus that drove the Cold War it
is the same animus that drives al-qaeda
this sincere conviction that you are
under attack by them Hitler believed to
his dying breath that Nazism was a
defensive reaction against the
encroachment of world jewelry he wasn't
pretending he wasn't saying that just to
manipulate people this was his driving
belief this is what he believed and this
is what this movement believes it
believes that Christians are the most
persecuted group in the
three Christians as a book by david
limbaugh russia's brother called
persecution and it makes the case if Tom
DeLay just said the other day Christians
are the most persecuted people in this
country this is not just pretense this
is part of a projective paranoid
mentality and it's one that has always
threatened democracy throughout the
history of man democracy has always been
threatened by paranoia this is why wars
have always destroyed Democratic and
Republican experiments this is why
Greece Athenian democracy collapsed
because of the Peloponnesian wars this
is why the Roman Republic collapsed
because of the Punic Wars because what
war does is it mobilizes that the spirit
of propaganda which sees enemies
everywhere in fact the real evildoer is
deep within the person looking for
evildoers so it's an impossible utterly
suicidal impulse it cannot function in a
democracy and when democracy is
functioning properly when the press is
free and independent and diverse when
the press reports the news when the
press tells people what's really going
on so that they can make rational
decisions about self-government my
belief is that by and large except for
periods extreme trauma the paranoid
element is in the minority took over in
1798 the war scare about the French the
passage of the Alien and Sedition Acts
it took over after World War one with
the Red Scare it took over in the early
50s with the bat Red Scare took over
after nine eleven but that's a fleeting
thing I you know corny as this must
sound I have faith in the judgment of
the American people if they know what's
happening and I believe the American
people more and more know that the
election was stolen Zogby did a poll a
few months ago finding that over eighty
percent of the american people want a
return to paper ballots they get it it's
the political establishment that doesn't
get it both parties in the press are in
an orbit
Carly separate from from from us and our
lives what I'm urging you all to do is
bear this in mind this is not about
being on the left this is not about
being a Democrat this is not about being
a coastal person this is not about being
in a blue state this is not a partisan
issue many Republicans didn't vote for
Bush this is not about being on the left
this is about realizing or salvaging the
values of the Enlightenment for the sake
of the pursuit of happiness you know I
mean in the in the good old days of the
Cold War we think we on the Left would
think great to nationalize the oil
industry I think would be great you know
national health care I mean it's what
most people want we should have that
look at this point if we had habeas
corpus freedom of speech checks and
balances the separation of church and
state we would be way ahead of where we
are now we would if we could get back
just those things that we came in with
we're all coming with them then we can
begin to talk about taking other steps
of various kinds but the point is to
stop thinking in terms of out groups
stop thinking in romantic terms and
start to think in terms of citizenship
as tedious as that may sound start
thinking in terms of coalition building
I have discovered in my own four-month
ordeal trying to scream everywhere I go
about the necessity of some kind of
election reform I found that some
genuine conservative Republicans
actually make better allies than any
number of machine liberals if they
believe in the bill of rights and the
rule of law they should be embraced so
you know what we really are all about
here is is something that used to sound
like a cliche to us but that is in fact
quite radical by contemporary standards
and that is the whole catalog of worldly
goods that the framers based this nation
on I know they had terrible
disagreements there was a lot of
reactionary energy among them I know all
this i know they owned slaves this is
all true the fact of the matter is they
believed in the pursuit of happiness in
this life they believed that all men are
created equal they believed in the
separation of church and state they've
lived in checks and balances they
believed they understood that it can
always happen here that's why they
designed the government the way they did
anyone who thinks it can't happen here
is completely estranged from their
thought and from that impulse the
pursuit of happiness is religion enough
thank
so we can take questions if people have
questions that come to the microphones
on either side and I would ask people
and when they pose their questions to
pose them as questions and not as
features and to limit your questions to
a minute at the most so where was once
thought lining up and you can take okay
come on Jeff it completely from what you
said you know carries reaction could you
explain by the press on the one hand and
particularly the left blogs blogosphere
and even bookstores this book as opposed
to other books is much harder to find in
bookstores so why the resistance from
the media in general and even this very
sympathetic left blogosphere on the one
hand and the people could make money off
of it the booksellers also seem to be
resisting well we're going to have to
pay a visit to the bookstores you've
been to hey Joyce it's actually in a lot
of bookstores he said nervously the
question about the media and the
progressive press is a very good one and
I think it does have much to do really
with the economic pressures I was
talking about earlier let's face it i
mean the presses is dominated by the
same cartel that dominates the rest of
the media it is therefore you know far
more it's far riskier than it's been in
decades to lose touch with which way the
wind is blowing right after election day
major US newspapers were not only not
looking into accounts of fraud and
anomalies and so on they were actively
ridiculing any attempt to raise the
question the Baltimore Sun the New York
Times The Washington Post they all ran
these smirking articles giggling at
those conspiracy theorists those weirdos
in the blogosphere those inhabitants of
the grassy knoll who had you know we're
crazy enough to think that an election
was stoned i mean at this point you know
just some months later it's just amazing
to me anyone could think that this
administration wouldn't do
that look at what they did do you know
still there was this sort of reflexive
derision and I think it's based on
careerism economic anxiety and this
extends you know I hate to say it but
extends over all the way over to the
left I mean the only negative reviews
that I received for this book we're in
mother jones and salon and in the one in
salon just really vicious and it was
written by a guy who my thang and the
acknowledgments to the book now this is
interesting his reporting prior to
election day was exemplary i got a lot
of stuff from his reporting because he
was tracking fraudulent activities as
soon as Election Day came this this guy
started writing pieces sneering at the
theory that the election was stolen so
when my book came out I is I'm assuming
he wanted to distance himself from the
Association so he called the pseudo
journalism he called the trash and was
really was personally vicious so vicious
that that you know was an irrational Act
so I you know I think people are scared
i think i think that's that's I don't
think there's like a formal lockdown
although they may be you know in TV or
something like that but these things
don't usually work that way as you know
yes I was asking you this at the
beginning of before you talk so let me
also throw it out to everyone um I have
a lot of students who really feel
frustrated they feel disenfranchised
they feel like they voted for the first
time and what good did it do them and I
don't want them to feel that way I want
to believe in democracy and I don't want
to stand up here and speechify but I I
want to thank you for standing up but
now what what do we do as intelligent
thinking people on both the right and
the left to make sure this doesn't
happen to us again well I appreciate
that question at people should feel
disenfranchised they were
you were we were and as it there's a
myth by the way that the young didn't
turn out to vote too apathetic they got
the ipod's on and so on they actually
turned out in record numbers at least
according to the studies by rock the
vote but that's one of these myths
that's used to justify the theft people
should feel disenfranchised but they
should not feel demoralized they feel
demoralized because Kari conceded
immediately and thereby handed the
Republicans a gift on a silver platter
so they could say see even their own
candidate doesn't think it was stolen
that was a terrible thing to do that was
in its way as bad as the theft itself
what I believe we should be doing is if
forcing the issue on to the national
agenda this is not just about young
people being disenfranchised not just
about african-americans being
disenfranchised what the Bush
administration has done is to return us
on mass to the Jim Crow era what black
people have been putting up with for a
hundred and thirty years it has now been
extended to the whole electorate you
know I believe that it's time now for
serious political action you ask what
does that mean well that means forming
coalition's that means making sure I
mean this isn't a problem the
Massachusetts so much but because your
your your election system is fairly
reliable here if you live in other
states which are trying to get the
machines introduced into the system you
got to fight it there are groups
fighting and join those groups more
generally we should be insisting that
this issue be number one that the press
cover that the politicians talk about it
is has to do with your enfranchisement
if you don't insist on it being
discussed now and dealt with now there
may come a time when there are no more
elections because we cannot
underestimate the radicalism of the
agenda here see it is it is radically
anti-feminist it is radically racist
it's all these things but you know this
is a point at which these issues cease
to be left concerns and become
fundamental American concerns what's
been happening to black people for 100
30 years they were like the Canaries in
the coal mine for a very long time they
certainly get it but you know oddly
enough the left press is very shy about
discussing this now there are some
promising signs in a month or so a major
article is going to come out in a very
well-known weekly written by a very
well-known public figure you know I'm
sorry I have to do this saying
categorically I was a skeptic you know I
read fooled again i read the Conyers
report I read Petraeus and wasserman's
book I read Steve Freeman's book they
stole it and he has has more evidence
this is a guy who knows a lot of people
okay when that happens we should be
pushing on that because this should be
it should be the battering ram because
if we don't work look it's probably too
late to prevent the theft of still more
votes in 2006 but it is not too late to
start thinking beyond Election Day what
we need and this is something that I
propose to all of you in dead earnest
what we really have to start thinking
about now is organizing a grassroots
exit polling operation in every place
where the race is sensitive because
they're not going to exit poll anymore
did you notice now the exit polls are
crucial they offer you a basis for
comparison see without exit polls
whatever they say goes and no matter how
badly the Republicans are doing now
doesn't really matter because you know
what will happen towards Election Day
the Republicans will drown us in
negative campaign advertising and the
race will tighten up somewhat and then
there'll be all these upset victories
and the press will say well the American
people decided to stick with George
Bush's party after all they always they
always interpret things in terms of what
propaganda steps the thieves took in the
first place that must be the reason they
won don't be complacent about their low
standing in the polls the Democrats are
playing a very risky game by figuring if
we do nothing we say nothing they'll
just implode and
and will take over they don't they don't
know what they're dealing with they
don't understand the VMS of this
position so you know anyone with a
practical or activist turn of mind
really should be thinking about
grassroots exit polling operations
bipartisan preferably using students but
there has got to be a basis for refusing
to acknowledge the election results
enough of this already okay happened in
two thousand by judicial Fiat it
happened in two thousand and forth
through a broad range of tactics we
can't just keep allowing the vote to be
subverted and just go about our business
I mean if we do that we deserve our fate
I hate to sound melodramatic you know
Jefferson said the price of freedom is
eternal vigilance I mean that really
means something he didn't say the price
of freedom is vigilance until we have a
Pentagon and we have a big banking
system and we all credit cards no it's a
trick because power the framers
understood so brilliantly the power will
always try to destroy freedom it will
always try to that is its nature it
wants to take over that's why we have a
system of checks and balances that's why
they take over the American government
by one party and the lunatic fringe
thereof is so profoundly dangerous this
Supreme Court is intended not just to
repeal roe v wade but to go much further
go home and do a Google search on the
Constitution Restoration Act which is
pending in Congress you know what that
is it's co-written by herb Titus who was
the lawyer of judge Roy Moore remember
judge Roy Moore he's the guy who
insisted on putting the graven image of
the Ten Commandments in the courthouse
in Arkansas and then the other judges
and the Supreme Court said take it out
he wouldn't he had to resign now he's a
big hero on the religious far right his
lawyer co-wrote the Constitution
Restoration Act which would essentially
declare that God is the sovereign basis
of American law
this would mean is the judges who make
decisions based on say Leviticus could
not be overruled you note that if you
read you Leviticus lately and is that
the death penalty for a lot of things
how much sexuality is just one of them
bestiality is just one of them heresy is
also one of them those astrology so it's
dishonouring your father and mother
everybody here in an analysis you I
can't say it know what this is this is
quite serious yes a little bit earlier
have have said to you that you have a
similar extreme or paranoid vision of
things what do you say response how do
you sure others that your research
procedures are in fact fair and
objective well all I can say is that
that is not an argument you know to to
define me as extreme or paranoid it's
not an argument that's an ad hominem
shot look at the evidence and tell me
whether the evidence is faulty tell me
how it's faulty because the this book is
copiously in meticulously footnote you
know 57 I mean I'm you know scholar and
obsessive about things like this and I'm
yeah I'm not Ann Coulter okay you know
with the phone notes she has phone notes
it's all there and and in fact I'm
delighted to say that that much of the
stuff that I found has been reconfirmed
by people in the trenches looking at the
precinct level data all over the country
I with some 40 pages on Florida and
fooled again professor Lance dehaven
Smith does statistics at Florida State
did a very very thorough study of the
precinct level data in South Florida and
you know everything that I discovered he
is found to be the case sometimes it's
even worse than than I thought and Bob
Petraeus who is running for governor of
Ohio as a green on a platform of
election reform because the Democrats in
Ohio they don't want to hear about it he
has been stud
the Ohio data and and it's taken even
his breath away the extent of the fraud
the invention of phantom votes for Bush
just the use of machines to
automatically a race between ten and
twenty percent of registered Democrats
so they show up at the polls in their
toll hey you're not registered well
that's okay take this provisional ballot
the provisional ballots dunno just get
thrown away it's just it's shocking you
know so I say you know you can insult me
all you like just tell me where the data
is wrong okay and also I like to say
this if this happened anywhere else
especially in a closed society or an X
satellite country of the Soviet Union
would we waste a second arguing over
whether there's maybe Saddam Hussein did
win by ninety nine point eight percent
of them maybe he did maybe he did a
really good job selling himself and the
mode of the electrode blah blah blah you
know oh we say this guy stole it you
know in Ukraine they're trying to steal
it we have the evidence no it happens
here you got people you know contorting
themselves to all kinds of bizarre
positions to come up with explanations
for the inexplicable I say that plus all
those you know once you get me started i
can't stop saying that's the problem
with being accused of insanity any
republican or let's say bush republican
or bush apologist who says you know
these machines are perfectly trustworthy
there's no evidence that they're not
which is patently false just ask that
person okay Hugo Chavez is now using
them Hugo she a venezuela like the guy
is not a conservative he signed a deal
with this company called smartmatic
which now owns Sequoia which is one of
the three major companies making the
machines and as soon as he did that it
was a coalition of conservative parties
in Venezuela decided to boycott the
election I'm with them right I don't
think he should use him either i don't
think anybody should use them so is it
okay for
wish to use them but not hugo chavez
those are some of the things i would say
hi i was wondering if you could say
anything about the evangelical right and
their disinterest in economic policies
that put us more and more into debt and
because Armageddon is coming and who
cares if we lose everything because it's
going to be the end of the world and
we're Christians and we'll be okay well
that's yeah the let's just give you a
little bit of background history when
the Cold War ended you know when war's
end there's often a kind of belated
surge of some kind of domestic violence
because all that fervor that's been
mobilized systematically for so long you
know it doesn't just disappear so after
World War one for example you know
things were pretty hairy in the United
States was a lot of virulent paranoia
deportations violence it's so on the
Klan was very very active then after the
first Gulf War the Kuwaiti people they
slaughtered Palestinians it was really
pretty bloody and the al-sabah dynasty
took advantage of this to purge its
political enemies and so on well the
Cold War was a different kind of war but
it did entail for decades of systematic
mobilization of American paranoia
towards the Soviet Union and vice versa
similar things happened over I mean it
the two dependent on each other it's
significant that when the Cold War ended
we then saw the the deflection of that
animus away from Moscow towards here
this is when the Clinton the the Clinton
hating cult began clinton became the
devil clinton became the Kremlin in
other words and liberals became the
Soviets and it was in the early 90s that
the Christian Coalition began
systematically
to take over the Republican Party this
is all in the book it's in other books
as well so what we have seen now is the
eventual result of that take over that
crusade I think there are some 18 states
where the Republican Party is actually
run by the religious right this is a
result of you know careful planning and
and you know long-term vision I mean
true their long-term vision doesn't
extend beyond the apocalypse which they
hope will be next month you know but let
me say this that all this time while the
right was taking over school boards
getting elected to state houses you know
running races seizing power most of us
on the Left were weren't the
multiculturalism and identity politics
and the result of that is that the right
got the government and the left got the
English department I sad but true so
it's time to play for you know real
stakes did I answer your question okay
yeah yeah I was wondering if you could
oh if you could say a little bit more
about the The Taming of the pollsters
because it seems to me that if you if
you believe the exit polls that people
who Valley who thought moral values were
important actually elected John Kerry
but some things are to be believed in
other things on it and yet it seems to
me we've heard very little from
pollsters that defends their profession
and what they did yes in fact Warren
metaph ski who runs the company that was
hired by the media to do the exit polls
Warren matowski who himself some years
ago spoke of the fact that exit polls
are unassailable and reliable did a 180
after the 2004 election and said these
exit polls were faulty his arguments
were based on the reluctant responder
thesis which is that Republicans are
more hesitant to answer questions about
how they voted than Democrats
okay it's an interesting theory now
steve freeman has you know scrupulously
red exit polling data at the precinct
level and is in fact found that if it if
anyone was slightly more reluctant to
respond to exit pollsters it was
democrats there's just no evidence for
that claim it sounds good but there's no
evidence for it I don't know matowski
but I assume that there's considerable
establishment pressure on someone as
prominent as he is it gets a lot of
business from major players and he's not
going to act like his hair's on fire you
know what I'm saying let me say that a
very important pollster a very
mainstream pollster will be quoted in
this aforementioned article to the
effect that the Republicans stole it so
that you know what I'm talking about now
the situation I'm complaining but it's
not going to last forever but i think
the thaw should come sooner than it
looks like it's going to come and it
should come as a result of your efforts
to make it happen three questions at
once okay bring it on two very brief
questions a lot of people that i know
felt that were shocked that howard dean
didn't win the Democratic nomination
because for two years the press and the
pollsters predicted that he was going to
win and I'm wondering whether the
Democrats you've spoken with don't want
to talk about your proposal because as
you said all parties cheap and
historically all parties have cheated
we've had both sides steal elections and
that the Democrats are studying the
Republican techniques and plan to to
adopt them in 2006 and perhaps 2008 and
whether any of your research shows that
that might be either something that did
happen in in Iowa or might happen in
2006 election as politics and science
that people are studying the behavior of
the Republican machine can I answer that
now Iowa has a [ __ ] an open caucus
system so while in theory it's possible
that Dean was you know illegitimately
deprived in his victory it's hard for me
to figure out how that would have
happened in Iowa now the fact about you
know the question about the Democrats
using the same devices the Republican
views I'm sure they might but the
important fact to notice that they don't
have to I don't have to do that why do
the Republicans gerrymander why do the
Republicans cheat on such a mammoth
scale why do the Republicans take such
pains to dominate the media right why do
they do all this because they cannot win
electorally they can't their agenda is
far too unpopular and here there are
many many people whom all of you would
i'm sure consider diluted or benighted
you know there's many people in that
camp who wouldn't support it either I
mean now there's a big evangelic apush
to do something about global warming
started last fall and just in February
there was a big organization created
they want it they want the government's
to do something to stem global warming
that's an evangelical effort see the
bush regime is apocalyptic suicidal it's
paranoid and that's not very popular
so they have to resort to these devices
see it's its central it's not just
another bad thing they do along with the
war and along with Katrina it's the
heart of the matter they must subvert
the people's will that isn't it obvious
that they act you know in complete
contempt of popular opinion and world
opinion are they always doing this you
know they don't care his bush care he
doesn't even seem to be worried that
many of his own fellow party members are
looking for the nearest exit because I
think he thinks and they figure in that
machine we got this thing we got this
thing all wrapped up or I hear you and
I'm with you and I've had these
arguments with people about the
apocalypse coming they want to bring it
on but most of the people that I argue
with our as you said the rational people
and they need evidence beyond what
you've told us today do you have any
further evidence that this is where
they're coming from yes yes let do your
friends a favor ask them to read with
God on their side by aster kaplan after
the reed kingdom coming by michelle
goldberg asking read american theocracy
by kevin phillips ask them to read
divine destruction by stephanie hendrix
and my own book cruel and unusual which
is the last one I wrote that'll that'll
do I mean if they're really you know if
they are indeed rational you know
they're going to have a hard time
dismissing all that evidence and show
them by the way direct them to some URL
where they can look into the
Constitution Restoration Act that should
get their attention hi I'm from The
Daily Collegian here at UMass and most
of the readers are students what message
would you like to get across to young
people today Wow
what message you want something succinct
but not like ranting or anything or
anything that my message is it that the
power is is yours but only if you seize
it let me say one last thing about the
left and mention another book that's
been unfairly overlooked by Lamar
Waldron and thom hartmann some of you
may have heard Thom Hartmann's radio
shows on air America is a book called
ultimate sacrifice it's about the
Kennedy assassination and these guys
worked on it for 17 years and it makes
an absolutely open-and-shut case the
Kennedy was killed by the mafia killed
by specifically Johnny Roselli Santo
Trafficante and Carla marchello the
godfathers of Chicago Tampa and Dallas
they wanted to kill the Kennedys because
the Kennedys vastly accelerated federal
prosecutions of the mob and of course
the mob had helped Kennedy at some
points in his political career but the
heat was intense because under Hoover
you know the government never really
went after the mob because the mob you
know had pictures of Hoover and his lacy
underwear and a lot of stuff so Kennedy
you know they really wanted to kill him
and they knew they could get away with
it because they had infiltrated a highly
covert operation that the Kennedy
brothers themselves were running
codenamed Operation em world this was a
plot to ferment a coup in Cuba have
Castro assassinated and then have
someone in the Cuban government who was
our agent and who is still in the Cuban
government takeover and turn Cuba into a
kind of social democratic paradise kind
of a Roosevelt Ian showcase not a
right-wing dictatorship this was
something that very few people were in
on a few CIA people were in on it just
enough to make it possible for the mob
to find out about this
operation because you know the mob and
the CIA had collaborated on some things
like trying to assassinate Castro so
there's a population of killers who
worked for both the mob in the CIA these
Godfather's understood the Bobby Kennedy
would do anything to prevent American
people in the world from finding out
about this operation because if the
Russians found out about am world a year
after the Bay of Pigs it could lead to
World War three consequently they knew
that if they set up a patsy at the scene
of the assassination was some kind of
cuban ties people with figure it was
Castro and Bobby Kennedy would never
allow anyone to find out the truth and
indeed the Warren Commission never was
allowed to find out the truth there was
big cover-up that's true there was a big
cover-up that's true the Oliver Stone
scenario that's false and the reason why
I mentioned this now is because I
believe that the whole mythology around
the Kennedy assassination has had a
profoundly paralyzing effect on
progressives and on liberals because it
gives us the idea no matter what noble
voices raised on behalf of righteous
causes they will cut him down like they
killed Kennedy and then they killed
Bobby that was a mob hit to Sirhan
Sirhan had mob connections so you know
because of this sort of religion which
is you know I think fairly scrupulous
Lee practiced in parts of the left we as
a fatal ism which suggests the political
action is pointless and I'm saying
political action is not only not
pointless it's it's crucial it's
essential it is finally what this system
is all about now we've been much
depoliticized by the consumer culture
everybody in here knows this you know
we're not much into you know civic
virtue you know subjugating our own
desires for the greater good but you
know it doesn't mean it's irreparable
because when push comes to shove when
people finally find that they themselves
are suffering horribly
for political reasons it can really wake
them up this is what happened in the
Vietnam War and I'm not in any sense
happy about this it's a tragic and
painful process but people are not repre
Blee stupid they're not just you know
ape-like yokels who just don't get it
people do get it and it's important for
us to understand that and to work with
them and young people especially should
be adamant about keeping the right to
vote because if you don't keep that all
your credit cards are going to be for
naught okay thank you
mark Crispin Miller is a professor in
the culture and communications
department at New York University for
more information on him and